A bell of awakening tolls and the
unkindled rises from his grave in the Cemetery of Ash.
Welcome, everyone, to Dark Souls 3.
In this episode we're going to be taking out the Ashen
Judge, exploring the new Firelink Shrine
and once again fighting through the Highwall of Lothric, except this time a new boss awaits
We start to explore, killing
all the scattered hollows that litter the graveyard
and the first item we pick
up is the Ashen Estus Flask on a corpse
of an elite knight which is surely a nod to Oscar, right? he was leaning on
He was leaning on something that looks suspiciously like a Lord Vessel.
There are actually three Lord vessel-like polls in this episode alone, so
see if you can spot them.
A bit of a challenge for you.
And then there's
this message: "pull back"
and as soon as you read this you're like:
"Oh, shit! I gotta go back!"
"This isn't safe. What if there's an Asylum Demon down here or an Ogre guarding treasure..."
"...or a giant Crystal Lizard that drops an incredibly valuable scale?"
These lizards are back with a vengeance.
I feel like finally they've evolved
to a more dangerous state and
are getting revenge for all their children that you've been killing in the past few games.
That's my headcanon for at least.
In terms of real story, their scale description says that:
"In rare cases crystal lizards devour souls,
growing to monstrous proportions."
And you might be noticing:
"That short bow is a little bit
better than it used to be, right?"
And it is.
I really like this playstyle where you
fall back for a few fast shots and then
when they close the gap, you slash at them with
melee its proactive and varied and fun
and I really like the way weapon arts
are shaping up so far.
We use this same technique really soon
against the boss of the tutorial
but first let's admire a few things:
First up, this 'arrow dodge', hit
detections are pretty on point.
And second: these views.
This build is running
on PS4 and it's definitely one-upped
Bloodborne graphically, in my opinion,
and see that over there?
That's the new Firelink Shrine
and guarding it is: Iudex Gundyr,
"The Ashen Judge".
Within his chest is the coiled sword, this sword is only bequeathed to chosen ash as judged by the
Iudex who awaits the arrival of ashes
as
and to quote another item description his back
has become a growing seedbed for
darkness, it doesn't feel right to commentate
this first fight, so enjoy.
Did you see what happened at the end there? That little moment where I checked for arrows threw me
off so much it stopped me dodging and I think it stopped me killing him too. Good fight though, right?
I was pretty on point with my
parries but that dagger made the fight really tough
didn't do so well with my parries in the second fight
I've got to admire this guy's move set and animations though.
In my final
fight I remember that this black tar
monster is pretty susceptible to fire.
Before we get into Firelink Shrine get a
loaded injured over here, this guy its an
absolute bastard you've thought the last boss was tough? Try fighting this naked dude
with a katana, whether it be the stun locking, my inability to parry him three times,
his god-like ability to parry
me? but after about eight deaths I found
his, well our weakness "gravity" now a lot of people are going to stubbornly kill
this guy like I did but a katana class
weapon this early on is a pretty sweet
reward and compared to bloodborne I can
confirm that this game is great at
giving you a lot of weapons in the early
game I had access to over 30 in the
first three hours which is awesome and
finally let's get into firelink shrine and
as we enter pay special attention to the
music I love how it intertwined with the
dialogue of the characters and the tone
it lends to this place.
The lords of cinder awoke but turned
their backs on their thrones and their
duty, it's our job to bring them back.
I got so nostalgic when i saw Andre at the end of this tunnel
I ran straight pass one of the hags from the Dark souls 2 and
went to talk to
our old blacksmith from Dark Souls 1
The blacksmith fulfills really familiar tasks plus the
ability to choose how many of each Estus Flask you'd like
The torch is the most appropriate thing to buy here for now but, I am definitely buying that key that
requires 20K souls. The handmaiden
also extends her wares when you bring her ash.
Ashes are the remains of Heroes you find
on your journey and the new items she
gets pertained to the type of ash that
you bring.
So the thrones belong to the Lords of
Cinder who abandoned them and very
fittingly they all seem to resemble
gravestones
for to sit upon them means sacrificing
yourself to link the fire.
Yhorm the Giant of the Profaned capital, the largest
throne of course.
Farron's Undead Legion "The Abyss Watchers", you can see their swords leated upon their throne.
Holy King Lothric, Last hope of his Line.
Aldrich "Saint of the Deep", you can see the almost
plastic-like covering around it
protecting it from his body and finally
Ludlef the Exiled who apparently still
remains on his throne
Leveling up remains much the same, but there's the addition of
the luck stat which makes a return from
Demon Souls. Luck increases item drop
rates as well as a few other minor
things probably and while we level up the
firekeeper is chanting something
Let these souls withdrawn from their vessels,
manifestations of disparity,
elucidated by fire burrow deep within me,
retreating to a darkness beyond the reach of flame,
Let them assume a new master, inhabiting in ash,
casting themselves upon new forms.
The mark of Ash will guide thee to the land of the Lords, to Lothric
where the homes of the Lords converge
so that was Firelink our new home for Dark Souls 3
and unlike in previous Dark Souls
games it doesn't seem to be connected to
the rest of the world so the closest
comparison to this hub will be Demon
Souls since that game had a disconnected
hub that you send in NPC's back to
but to me the strongest part of Dark Souls
was it's intertwined interconnected
world and areas including the hub so if
this is a step away from that, then I'm
honestly a little bit disappointed
because the ability to walk to every
checkpoint from a disconnected hub is
definitely going to affect exploration
and world design regardless though time
will tell if this is a problem or not
and once again we find our way through
the High Wall of Lothric where the
homes of the Lord of Cinder converge and
most of you have seen this area but
there are some new things, for example
all the enemies now drop items and since
I chose the gold coins as my gift i
ended up being able to increase my luck
and i got really, really lucky with my drops,
I'm gonna come right out and say
it out of all the footage that comes out
of this event on March 1st I reckon we
end up with the most fashionable
character consider that a challenge to
the other uploaders, I guess? And of
course since all these items dropped for
me I can teach us a lot about the Lothric Knights
these Knights of Lothric
with their Drake's once crushed anything
that threaten their shores of course that
was a long long time ago the knight has
served as one of the three pillars since
ancient times and shares place alongside the Wyverns
as a symbol of Lothric
on the flip side though the Lothric
knights are also said to have contended
with the dragons and their shields have
lightning resistance which is befitting
of a dragon slayers arms
their crossbows are also blessed with the
power of lightning in anticipation of
the use of lightning bolts which we know
are effective against dragons so they
fight with and against dragons and the
Lightning Urn explains this to us it tells
us that "The Knights of Lothric have since tamed
dragons but were once hunters of dragons"
and finally they worshipped the Sun so
many connections here between Lothric
the land of the Lords, lightning, Sun,
Gwyn it's all here as we enter Lothric
castle we expect the dancer of the
Frigid Valley but now in her place is
Emma who sits beneath a restricted ladder
leading deeper into Lothric Castle
A castle rumored to devour men.
Forge on through the great gate and raise this banner to proceed
this farewell gift is for you it is the insignia
of an old Covenant if you feel trespassers
Covenants are now changed belong the fly, which is great
there's an inventory slot that holds
your allegiance
go through the great gate and raise this
banner to proceed but beware the dog
keeps a close eye on things, the vile watchdog of the Boreal Valley
In episode two we face off against the
vile watchdog and we find an old friend in a
town I can't wait to show you guys that,
it's gonna be amazing I don't usually
ask this but if you could leave a like
that would be so fantastic I really want
this series to do well and this series
is going to get better come March 24th
when the Japanese version comes out
because I won't have time restrictions
on the amount of content I can upload so
we'll be able to go more in depth on so
many of the interesting things that I
had to cut out of this series in the
name of time restrictions you guys have
no idea how hard it is to cut down like
six hours of footage to a mere 45
minutes or so that's been really tough
and also having the full game on March
24th means I'll be able to record at my
own pace not just in one big sitting so the
production value will go up and I just
want to say thank you for supporting
this series, thank you for watching,
thanks for being patrons if you are and I'll see you in the next one